understanding variation is one of the
key lenses of our theory of improvement
as improvers we aim to reduce the
variation of process and create a
process that achieves a certain level of
reliability one tool that can help us
understand variation is a histogram a
histogram is a chart that can help us
understand the distribution of
continuous data so for example let's
imagine you work in a federally
qualified health center and you are
tasked to improve the patient cycle time
in a clinic the patient's total time
from appointment start time to
completion is important to the patient
experience and important to the clinic's
efficiency so using a data collection
form you collected this data for the
cycle time of patients in a single day
so imagine here we've got our minutes
going along the left-hand column and
we've got the number of patients that
had a cycle time within that time
interval on the right-hand column and so
what we're gonna do is draw the actual
histogram and histogram looks very much
like a bar chart but the bars are
organized by the time interval so let's
let's draw our bar chart and again we're
working on cycle time and along the
x-axis we're gonna put in our x here so
we've got 10 20 30 40 50 60 and then I
just lumped anything that's over 60
because for the most part we we don't
want that and then on this side so this
is I put my time here it's good to label
your access on this side I'm going to
put my number of patients so I'll go 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 and again this this is the
y-axis and I want to label that as well
so people can who can see this know what
it is that we're tracking so now I can
come along here with my data and we just
create we go with each time interval and
we create a bar
corresponds with the number of patients
so in for patients that waited only 10
minutes those those lucky few we're
gonna come along and we will do two
patients it will make a bar just colored
in so it's a little bit easier to look
at great so now as you look at your
cycle time data you can look for the
number of patients that had cycle times
in each of the various time intervals
once you've plugged in all the data
you'll see the distribution to the data
and better understand the variation that
exists within your process so two things
to look for at this start is does this
histogram show a distribution that
appears symmetrical so if you look at
this chart for example it looks kind of
like a mountain right so it's pretty
symmetrical now it doesn't mean that you
like the variation that exists in the
times that are here or that you're happy
with the amount of time but this kind of
shows that you've got a process that
doesn't have any outliers and and now
you can work on trying to figure out how
to reduce the variation and reduce the
time to whatever is appropriate for what
you're trying to improve now in some
cases you might encounter an example
where for example here we came along and
let's imagine this one's just off the
charts and it's actually 10 or 12
minutes or even higher and you notice
that this particular interval has an
outlier or something that just jumps out
at you it says there's something else
going on here that's a you know an area
that we need to figure out and so that
can be a helpful thing to point out when
you're looking at your histogram to
identify if there are some special
places that may be in a certain time
interval or after a certain point
there's something unusual that's outside
the symmetry of the process
you